this episode of real science is brought
to you by curiositystream
sign up today at curiositystream.com
real science and get free access to
watchnebula.com
we all know we should donate blood but
probably don't as much as we should
every year almost 5 million americans
need blood transfusions and would likely
die without them
approximately 32 000 pints of blood are
used each day in the united states
for people who lose blood during
operations or from traumatic injuries
others need blood transfusions because
of ongoing illness like sickle cell
anemia
where they will need transfusions
throughout their lives the network of
blood donation and transfusion in any
country
is a hugely vital part of keeping sick
or injured people alive and well
this wouldn't be so complicated if we
all had the same type of blood
but we don't and some of us have such
rare blood types
that any injury any procedure or any
accident can be life threatening
imagine your blood was so rare and so
unique that should you get hurt
almost no one else in the world's
donated blood would be able to save you
so rare and so valuable that your
identity needs to be concealed to keep a
never-ending stream of requests for it
at bay
so rare that scientists would do almost
anything to get their hands on a pint of
it to study
for the people who have the rarest blood
type in the world rh
knoll this is their reality it's the
world's most dangerous blood type to
have
because only 43 people in the world are
discovered to have it
meaning if you get hurt basically no one
else's blood would be compatible with
yours
injuries that would be serious but
treatable for everyone else
would probably be fatal for you most of
us have
probably heard of the usual blood type
system or even know our own blood type
o positive a b negative a positive o
negative
this classification determines who we
can donate blood to or receive it from
there are a total of 33 different
classification systems recognized
but most people only need to worry about
the two most common ones
the [ __ ] and rh systems the [ __ ] system
classifies blood based on the presence
of antigens
antigen a and antigen b you can have one
or the other
both or neither antigens are
glycoprotein markers
embedded in the cell membrane and help
your immune system to distinguish
between your body's
own cells and foreign cells like viruses
or bacteria
in an a blood type the a antigen is
found on the blood cell itself
and an a or anti-b antibody is found in
the blood serum
in a b blood type a b antigen is found
on the blood cells and a b
or anti-a antibody is found in the serum
blood type a b
has both a and b antigens on the blood
cells and
neither of the corresponding antibodies
against them in the serum
and blood type o has neither antigen on
the cells but has antibodies a
and b in the serum when blood is donated
the red blood cells are separated from
the plasma where the antibodies are
located
through a process called blood
fractionation this ensures that only the
red blood cells get donated
and not their corresponding antibodies
since that would cause an adverse
reaction
in the recipient your immune system will
produce antibodies against
any blood antigens you don't have in
your own blood
therefore a person with type a blood
that receives b blood
would have an [ __ ] incompatibility
reaction
the anti-b antibody present in the
patient's blood would agglutinate with
the b
antigens on the donated red blood cells
making the blood cells clump together
and block small blood vessels
the immune system would then attack the
new blood cells and destroy them
it's rare for this to happen but if it
does it is serious and potentially fatal
transfusion is considered safe as long
as the serum of the recipient
does not contain antibodies for the
blood cell antigens of the donor
so this is why if you have type a b
blood you're a universal recipient
you don't have either of the antibodies
that would attack a or b
donor blood however this also means you
can only donate blood to other people
who have a b
blood if you have type o blood your
universal donor
you can give your blood to a b a b or
o without triggering their immune system
but this is also why
people with o blood can only receive
type o blood
however there are other antigens that
need to be accounted for
beyond the ones in the [ __ ] system before
donating or receiving blood safely
this is where the rhesus system comes in
the rhesus or
rh system is the second most significant
blood group system
these are the most important antigens
but the most significant one being the d
antigen although there are lots of other
rh antigens
rhd is the most significant because it's
the most likely of the rh antigens to
produce an immune response
depending on whether the rhd antigen is
present each blood type is assigned a
positive or negative symbol
people who are rhd negative can only
receive rhd negative blood
but people who are rhd positive can
receive either rhd positive or
rhd negative blood the negative blood
types a negative
b negative a b negative and o negative
are more rare than their positive
counterparts
and while the d antigen is the most
important one in the rh system
there are a total of 60 other rh
antigens making it the largest of any of
the blood classifications
and while these eight blood types are
the most common way of describing our
blood
each of these eight types can be
subdivided much further
there are millions of varieties each
classified according to the exact
antigens that coat the surface of our
red blood cells
to know your exact blood type you'd have
to write it out antigen by antigen
luckily for most of us many of the
antigens we have
don't affect our ability to receive or
donate blood because pretty much
everyone else
also has them for example more than 99.9
percent of people carry the antigen
called vel
so for most of us donating blood to one
another we wouldn't need to worry about
this antigen
as it wouldn't trigger an immune
response but for every five
thousand people there's one person who
does lack the vale antigen who shouldn't
receive blood from the other 4999
their immune system recognizes the vel
antigen as foreign
and if given vel positive blood they
could have kidney failure and possibly
die
but doctors do screen for as many of
these variants as possible
to make sure to find the best match for
a blood transfusion
but sometimes this best match isn't
really possible
and this is why the rarer your blood the
harder things get
the world's rarest blood type rh null is
called
rh null because it has none of the 61
antigens present in the rh
blood system we previously discussed it
is rare enough to have a few of the
antigens in the rh system missing from
your blood
but the chances of missing them all are
astronomically small
doctors call it the golden blood because
for anyone who has
any type of rare rh blood type missing a
few antigens here or there
the rh no blood can be accepted where
other more typical blood types could not
be
it has enormous life-saving capabilities
but for those who have it it can be a
curse
most of us likely take for granted that
if we get hurt
the nearest hospital will be able to
sort us out but if you're one of the few
with rh no blood
life is inherently more dangerous you
can't receive blood from anyone else
except the 42 other people that exist
who have been found to have the same
blood type
and of the people known to have it only
a handful of them are active donors
and they're spread across the world and
the logistics of shipping blood around
the world are stupidly complicated
bureaucracy and paperwork can hold
things up at the borders which can
create a myriad of issues
fresh blood has a shelf life of 4 weeks
and it has to be stored at 4 degrees
celsius
which is challenging during
transportation especially to remote
areas
this means that any holdup at customs
can render the blood unusable
and some countries have very restrictive
rules in regards to importing blood
the uae for example won't accept any
blood into the country that isn't from
the gulf states
these types of logistics and bureaucracy
make it very hard for someone with rare
blood to get a transfusion
especially in a sudden emergency where
they need the blood fast
for one swiss man with rh null blood
this meant as a child
he couldn't go to summer camp or do
outdoor sports because his parents
feared he could get an injury with no
ability to get a blood transfusion
as an adult he can't travel to countries
without modern hospitals
the only realistic way he can navigate
this danger is to continuously donate
blood to himself meaning twice a year he
donates blood to keep on reserve in case
he ever needs it
and he can't really donate much more
than that because rh null blood also
comes with some adverse effects
the rh antigens that most of us have are
thought to play a role in maintaining
the integrity of the red blood cell
membrane
red blood cells which lack rh antigens
have an abnormal shape and an
increased osmotic fragility this means
that red blood cells break down quicker
than they should
resulting in a hemolytic anemia this can
lead to fatigue
shortness of breath and jaundice and
thus makes frequent blood donation
impossible
and because only a handful of people
with this rare blood ever donate it
this places a large burden on those who
do when someone else needs this type of
blood
because rh no blood can be donated to
anyone with a rare combination of rh
negatives in their blood type
every once in a while they may get an
urgent call to donate
the swiss man we mentioned before once
got a call that a newborn baby was in
dire need of his type of blood
to save the baby's life he would need to
make his way to the donation center
this meant taking a taxi to geneva and
taking time
off of work none of which is allowed to
be reimbursed due to the blood donation
laws in some parts of europe
he was able to help in this instance but
quickly realized that the cost and
burden of donating his valuable blood
would ultimately fall on him anyone with
this rare type of blood is given the
gift of being able to help someone at a
time of need
an ability to help where no one else can
it probably feels pretty amazing to know
you've played a part in saving someone's
life
but this also comes with the unfortunate
burden of being in a sense
on call for your entire life should the
need for your blood arise
this poses an interesting ethical
question it's up to you to donate blood
at a moment's notice
whether you're in a client meeting at
your own wedding or on vacation
at what point does your moral obligation
to help someone else in need begin and
end
but for every person who was otherwise
doomed without this donated blood
the importance of it obviously can't be
overstated and this serves as a reminder
that hospitals around the world rely on
the good deed of blood donation to save
lives
whether your blood is rare or not since
the very first blood transfusions in the
1800s
they have saved millions of lives and
played a vital role in shaping our
modern world
in times of peace they've saved citizens
from unfortunate accidents
and in times of war have saved the lives
of countless wounded soldiers
during world war ii the american red
cross flew almost 200
000 pints of whole blood from the us to
the allied forces in europe
more than 50 000 pints of blood were
needed for the soldiers fighting during
the d-day invasion of normandy alone
the level of coordination needed for the
collection and transport of this much
blood is astounding
and you can learn more about logistics
like this in real engineering's new
logistics of d-day series available
exclusively on nebula
the streaming platform made by the best
educational content creators
like wendover productions medlife crisis
braincraft and our other channel real
engineering
nebula is a place for us to make
experimental and creative videos without
worrying about the youtube algorithm
it has loads of original content like
the logistics of d-day series
that you can watch ad-free by signing up
to curiositystream
or bundling nebula with every sign-up
that uses the link in the description
with this subscription you'll get access
to thousands of high-quality
documentaries on curiosity stream
like the three-part series called the
body which covers fascinating new
insights into medical research
but you'll also get access to all my new
videos completely ad-free
get to watch all of the new nebula
exclusive series
and be supporting a community of
creators who love bringing you the most
exciting
original content we can
you